qué pensarían si les dijera que para mí
todos ustedes no son humanos
normalmente suelen verme así o así mis
amigos mi familia que le cuento esto
pero no no tengo ninguna enfermedad ni
estoy borracho soy un poco raro yo lo sé
pero no soy mejor que ustedes se desea
practicar una pequeña historia para que
vean porque pienso así
todo comenzó cuando estaba en tercero de
kinder ahí estaba yo sentado en el salón
esperando a que llegara mi maestra
platicando con mis amigos lo que
platicas esa edad que vamos a jugar en
receso que está mamando tu mamá de
lonche cuando de repente
volteo y alguien abre la puerta era una
mujer flaquita alta de cabello oscuro
unos ojos tapatíos
tipo angelina jolie hace cuentas sí
que ve
impactado quedé asombrado total empezó a
la clase y yo quería formar parte de su
clase quieres que me tomar en cuenta
entonces todo lo que pedía ella yo lo
quería hacer que quién va a limpiar la
mesa yo teacher que cuando estuve los
top four teacher
yo quería responderle a todo
en esa época de mi vida mi abuela pasaba
por mí por mis hermanos al colegio y los
llevaba a la casa a su casa yo siempre
que llegaba a la casa de mi abuela le
contaba todo lo que ha pasado en mi vida
mi abuelo pero ese día en especial yo
quería llegar evidenciaba por llegar y
contarle a mi abuelo todo lo que había
sentido y vivido ese día de platicar le
a quien había encontrado que había
sentido el enamoramiento por primera vez
llegué a la casa con mi abuelo y empecé
a platicar que siguen flaquita alta y
angelina jolie y empezó a platicar me y
después mi hijo a ver a ver cálmate
se rió si se arriba un poco sarcástico
pero se puso algo serio
me siento me puso su mano sobre mi
hombro y me dijo una frase que hasta el
día de hoy recuerdo perfectamente
mira fer
nadie ni nada en este mundo puede
resistirse al poder de la poesía
escríbele reclamarle a tu maestra así
como dice con tu abuela
poesía que es este poder que dice mi
abuelo
poesía pasaban los días le preguntaba a
mi abuelo que era este tema me contaba
algunos tips que no ser tan miedoso que
como lo hizo con mi abuela como declamar
etcétera pasó un ciclo escolar llegué a
primaria con nociones de escritura y la
maestra nos pidió redactar nuestra
primera carta pero ojo esa carta tenía
que ser sumamente especial para alguien
único
todos acaban de escribir a mi tía ya mi
mamá yo a mi abuela no hay a mi prima
pero yo
yo solo pensaba
mi maestra suplente de inglés si no me
voy a quitar de la cabeza total nos dio
la maestra de la hoja en blanco y en
cuanto puse la primera gota de tinta o
lápiz nueva por con que escribamos en
primaria no pare de escribir y no me
detenía y sentía que estaba vivo sabía
que tenía alma
y me di cuenta que en ese momento había
encontrado algo que la mayoría de las
personas tardan toda la vida inclusive o
no lo encuentran
llamada pasión yo había encontrado a mi
corta edad la pasión llamada poesía yo
he descubierto esto de letras escribir
inspirado y terminé de escribir la carta
un corazoncito por aquí otro por acá lo
doblé elósegui un corazoncito más porque
no y ahora llega el momento de
entregarse llegó la salida la vi de
lejos corrí hacia ella y sin verla la
cara se le entregué y corrí
pasó el día siguiente yo ansioso en el
salón me asomé a ver si llegaba
y ya nunca volví a saber nada de ella
nunca más voy a saber algo de ella yo
quiero pensar que lo mejor ya no quiso
regresar porque se enamoró o no sé no sé
que habrá escrito
pero de esta historia no no es para que
piensen que soy un niño precoz ni nada
por el estilo de aquí yo aprendí dos
grandes ideas la primera que un niño de
kinder no puede enamorar a su maestra
bueno hay una excepción del presidente
de francia que no sé cómo le hizo pero
creo que ésta se casó con su maestra
escribirle tips y la segunda y más
importante que la poesía no solamente se
escribe sobre un trozo de papel sino que
la poesía es vida y la vida por sí misma
es poesía
y es poesía pues ya no es no es
romanticismo no es un género literario
no es cursilería aburrido para textos
para niñas como estaban diciendo a lo
largo de mi vida si no quieres cubrir un
lado desconocido de la poesía que es un
estilo de vida en mi caso yo voy
escribiendo mi poema mi gran poema de la
vida en un trozo de papel
y ahí se va escribiendo conforme lo que
vaya viviendo con mis pasiones puede ser
triste melancólico feliz pero se va
escribiendo
pero tal es el caso de michael jordan el
gran basquetbolista todos los conocen él
escribía poesía en un lienzo diferente
él escribía poesía en la cancha de
basketball y ponían a michael jordan en
la cancha de basketball y encestaba y se
llenaba de vida sabía que estaba
diseñado para eso o por otro lado marie
curie la gran científica que engrandeció
a las mujeres ella escribía poesía en su
laboratorio al experimentar
al investigar ya sabía que estaba viva
no se necesita ser famoso o reconocido
para escribir poesía no cada uno de los
que estamos aquí estamos escribiendo un
poema si todos somos escritores aunque
no nos guste y es que puede que piensen
que soy un poco más raro de lo normal
pero yo veo la vida desde otro punto de
vista
literal con otros ojos
se puede que piensen que son bárbaro
pero no yo no veo un rostro yo no veo un
humano por aquí yo creo que detrás de
cada uno usted se está escribiendo un
poema cada quien está haciendo a su
manera a su tinta que es la personalidad
y cada quien va escribiendo lo que tan
extenso sea tan divertido tan deprimente
pero aquí quisiera preguntarles ustedes
ya encontraron donde están escribiendo
poesía de que está tratando
llegó el año 2007
maldito año 2007 yo estaba muy feliz
escribiendo mi poema un poco arrugado
manchado de cat su normal cuando de
repente mi abuela nos recogió nos llevó
a la casa y sentí un ambiente diferente
un ambiente tenso
incómodo
no sé si les ha pasado pero como cuando
van a la casa de su suegra y le cuentan
un chiste y no se ríe
seguro le pasado así ha sido incómodo
pero me asomé y vi algo extraño mi mamá
estaba el fondo de la habitación
qué raro no me llegaba hasta después de
trabajar así que corrí a saludarla pero
cuando entré ese cuarto me congelé me
petrifica
simplemente dejé de parpadear y es que
me le quedé observando a su cara
su cabello
y me di cuenta que no tenía no tenía
cabello
y le colgaba un tubo que llevase a una
bolsa con un líquido interno muy oscuro
un rojo oscuro creando la tinta
era sangre
en ese momento y no sé qué está pasando
pero sabía que era malo pasaban 23 horas
mi papá nos reunió a mis hermanos ya mí
y lamentablemente nos comentó
le habían detectado
cáncer de mama a mi madre
en ese momento
este poema
[Aplausos]
se destruyó
lo pisotea
a mi corta edad de nueve años
dejé vivir sin pasión
no sabía qué hacer
simplemente no tenía pasión sin embargo
yo voltea a ver a mi mamá mientras yo
estaba arrumbado tirado chille estás por
ahí yo me estaba escribiendo un
grandioso poema
una epopeya de la felicidad parecía que
éstas que no con tanta entusiasmo en un
poema de felicidad de alegría de anhelos
de esperanza
en ese momento me levanté agarre mi
poema y seguí escribiendo el gran poema
de vida
me di cuenta que nadie agarro mi trozo
de papel y lo tiró fui yo mismo quien lo
hizo inspirado y mamá que
afortunadamente sigue escribiendo su
gran poema está aquí presente ante
ustedes
yo sigo continuando escribiendo sigo
escribiendo mi vida sigo escribiendo y
poesía y aquí voy con esto
me he percatado a mi corta experiencia
que las letras seducen miradas
enamoran maestras bueno ese no fue mi
caso
pero sobre todo confío firmemente
en que cada uno de nosotros no somos
humanos
aunque los filósofos enojen no somos
humanos sino que
todas y todos
somos poesía
[Aplausos]